well dude that's because when it comes
down to it you don't really know
anything about fitness all right all
right I read a little comment that said
um Cody doesn't know anything about
fitness can I read it yeah I found that
hilarious
can I read the comment yeah I know what
way no you know you were applied to a
different one
well it I'm howling to a different one
that was like no no I never on me no I
didn't reply to that one oh you didn't
no no the one the fitness one I yeah
yeah but we were talking about it I
thought that was very funny to me
specifically because it when I'm Cody
and I have talked about fitness outside
of podcast in the past it's funny just
how matter-of-fact you say things that
other people just don't like we were
tight be like I don't know like one time
we're talking about curls and you're
like yeah I don't know I just put on
muscle really easy I don't have to crawl
that much I never said that did I yeah
you said that to me I mean I do put on
muscle pretty easily
yeah what I'm sorry you know I just
don't know I just curl a little bit and
get it back Mike nice dude no but this
is from years and years of being an
athlete well that you don't know my body
is that's why I was able to like not run
for a long time and then like just train
for four weeks and be able to do like a
half marathon yeah but you don't have
time you don't know what you're talking
about it comes to fitness
that's what okay let me read this
comment let me read this comment this is
a comment we got on patreon so in the
last episode we made the mistake of
talking about fitness and I was talking
about how lifting doesn't make you
healthy makes you strong all right maybe
I should have been maybe I should have
been a little bit more clear and I don't
claim to know the science behind this at
all okay maybe I should have said that
like getting big doesn't make you
healthy right like you saw the [ __ ]
videos we watch this video of these
bodybuilders it was like a document like
a vice documentary on steroids oh yeah
these guys are walking around their home
they're huge massive massive dudes and
they're walking on their homes out of
breath constantly yeah yeah they're
[ __ ] so unhealthy they're gonna sick
all the time
you got acne all over the place yeah you
know saying but they're giant they're
strong acne that's not what I was
talking about you get kids so many boy
no no no I'm in school Dagny like feel
what emails podcast you alright you look
sick that's not what I'm saying
sick some wrong with you you got a virus
he makes look makes you look think about
what I'm saying I'm saying you know you
eat like a lot of fast food that's when
you break out yeah some you know I'm
saying it's like you got a good balance
at least when you're older like that
should when that [ __ ] happens to me is
when I'm eating one like chocolate
that's when I break out yeah it's like
when your hormones are [ __ ] it
imbalanced so anyways this girl goes
Amanda right and now Amanda I love you I
love you for being a patron I appreciate
you very much but this comment she goes
Cody I love you but you have absolutely
no idea when your talk what you're
talking about when it comes to fitness
ah-ha-ha-ha-ha and that part the end
that hahaha that starts with an A ahaha
so condescending and I read that I got
just so offended and I wrote out this
car so you've read this copy pasta no
don't I just want to say okay
I got to go in for a second yeah all
right goin read your copy pasta because
I want everyone to take this out and
copy paste it I can't
the cables do so it's so funny
I'm just saying okay look I've been an
athlete competitive athlete or I was one
for 12 years yeah right that was ten
years old mm-hmm national level I won
nationals one time yeah I went to I
qualified for one Olympic Trials I came
like eight in Olympic Trials went to
qualify for the 2012 ones too didn't go
but qualified for them uh was a d1
collegiate athlete for four years I've
done every type of lifting there is you
know how Olympic lifting powerlifting
everything yeah and everything in
between and I've done two marathons and
done four or five half marathons you
would think I know what I'm talking
about when it comes to fitness
absolutely not you don't think I know
what I'm talking about
absolutely not why because this is
because I've never done strong lifts
like a man dies I feel like I don't know
what you're maybe you know maybe you
study in squad I'll admit that I don't
know the science behind this [ __ ] I
don't know the science but I've done
this [ __ ] for years and years yeah my
dad is on the most fit people on the
[ __ ] planet
it's done like 50 ultramarathons
including this one coming up it's a
hundred and fifty miles insane in the
[ __ ] antarctica in the antarctic in
arc and somewhere Alaska that's where it
is somewhere and somewhere cold this
flask is cold as [ __ ]
150 [ __ ] miles yeah this dude has a
world record doesn't I doesn't really
know what he's talking about he doesn't
know what he's talking about
I just loves laying that he can do all
that but you don't really not you're
talking about with all due respect you
don't know what you're talking about
yeah just just you know you know if
there's years and years of [ __ ] what
if that was just a troll and she was
doing like the senator thing yeah the
congressman thing yeah all due respect
mm-hmm I just want to say you don't know
what you're talking about my times up go
ahead congressman well I actually
disagree so so I move carry on now I
will give you some credit here though I
am not in shape right now yeah and I'm
not I don't look like I know what I'm
talking about when it comes in this
because I don't abide by it how would I
know
yeah sorry I had to go in for a second
about your chest yeah that that's the
first time we've seen you upset I got
like a you know I got like I let me talk
to your manager upset it yeah most
definitely
this girl thinks it no not today
oh here it goes today it goes here it
goes Amanda I want to know what your
what is your experience with Fitness
you're probably super jacked you chicken
every single day for every meal and so
I'll give you that maybe maybe you do
know how to stay up in shape that's
great I'm just saying I know about other
athletic athletic elites elite athletes
what if you said hey Amanda and it's
just Lance Armstrong sends us a tweet
hey guys using my daughter's account I
just want to say Cody you have still no
[ __ ] idea what you're talking to them
I would be like all right Lance do your
damn thing I'm sorry flex
not trying to flex and I'm holding half
his bags I'm trying to flex not trying
to flex take your vision notion break
that's not a flex